hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter five
of his prologue to the spokes are
thooose drah Zarathustra speaking as
nature's mouthpiece talks about a type
or configuration or state of humanity
that is a live possibility for us and
may in fact be realized for many people
in the present he calls it the last or
ultimate man the letzte mensch so this
is a final state of humanity but it's
not a good one and it's being contrasted
against another possibility which is the
ubermensch or Superman and this would be
something that we would arrive at
through our own you know social planning
and the gradual work of centuries
building up say technology or social
structures or and it really is a live
possibility for us today perhaps in a
way that that goes beyond the time that
Nietzsche might have envisioned if you
think about the future that's coming for
us with you know robotics and AI and
incredible developments and logistics
that could potentially afford us the
possibility of like never leaving
our little apartments unless we happen
to be one of the people tinkering around
with the robots and systems and you know
so what we what we call sort of a
post-scarcity economy the way it's being
spelled out one of the ways it could
look like would be this this picture of
the last met the the final state of
humanity and he brings it up in a
dramatic situation the crowd he sees
doesn't really want to hear about the
Superman he says there they stand he
said to his heart there they laugh they
don't understand me I am NOT the mouth
for these ears so he goes on he says
what's the problem with these they have
something of which they are proud what
is it called that makes them proud it
says they call it culture German
building building has a sort of double
meaning to it it means culture it also
means education or formation and in
their view this culture is what makes
them better than previous humans who are
just a bunch of you know barbaric stupid
at counter purpose is sort of Apes we
have culture and that allows us to live
together as human beings who don't
always have to be causing trouble with
each other and can get along or you know
when we don't get along it can be fairly
trivial and we can get over it and you
know we don't be threatened by those who
want to bring about exciting things
because you know culture will keep that
at bay and so he says they're really
proud of this what is it he says they
call it culture it distinguishes them
from the goatherds therefore they don't
like me talking about contempt fare
actin sort of like being you know
looking at things as we say with the
jaundiced eye they don't like to hear
that it's not nice and he says they
don't want to hear the word contempt
spoken of them but you know relation to
the Superman so I'm going to speak to
their pride
Stolz all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
speak to what they think is great about
themselves I'm gonna tell them about the
last men and you could imagine that that
Zarathustra maybe has in his mind I'm
gonna spell this possibility out for
them if they're not going to go for the
the Superman where they're gonna end up
and they'll be like oh I don't want that
I'm too good for that that's not what
actually happens SVC in the end of the
the section so what would be going on
with this last man one way of thinking
about it is that the human potential
becomes weakened becomes exhausted and
is no longer able to produce the sort of
people that that at least we are still
today he says that it's time for human
beings to fix their goal it's time to
plant the seed of the highest hope our
soul is still rich enough for it but one
day this soil will will still be poor
and weak no longer will a high tree be
able to grow up from it so that's one
metaphor right there we we can exhaust
the fecundity the fertility the capacity
to provide nutrients and a locus for
something greater to grow out of us he
also says the time is coming when man
will no longer shoot the arrow of his
longing out of her mankind and the
string of his bow will have forgotten
how to twang yet another metaphor there
for an incapacity to imagine something
greater to desire even something greater
than the condition that you you have
there and he says I tell you one must
have chaos in wanting to give birth to a
dancing star I tell you you still have
chaos within you so you're not totally
lost you're not the last man yet bought
your clothes and you have to be careful
about that so what is the last man like
Nietzsche tells us that the last man can
no longer despise or feel contempt for
actin himself he can no longer tell how
badly off he
is as a matter of fact he thinks that he
is better than the people who came
before he's not gonna stress it of
course because that wouldn't be good
taste and why get so worked up over
anything like that
so he says the time is coming when
nobody's gonna give birth to any more
stars the time of the most contemptible
man is coming the man who can no longer
despise himself I will show you the
ultimate man so now he's gonna sketch
out the picture of what this person is
like and the metaphor that he uses over
here is the last man says things and
then blinks sort of like you know
looking in the Sun or they've just woken
up from a stupor they're not really
ready for dealing with life but their
life is easy so they can blink all they
want til they get the sleep out of their
eyes and then they get on with something
then they take another little nice
little nap right or doze off doing what
they're doing so one way of thinking
about this is they can no longer place
themselves into relation with anything
really human anything really beyond
themselves he says what is love
well love is something that takes us
outside of ourselves when we love
something we're willing to sacrifice it
what is creation nothing needs to be
created anymore
what is longing what is desire what is
the you know need for something else and
then he says what is a star now you
might say well what what's that doing in
there all of these things are like human
activities or they are you know feelings
that we have why a star well because the
star symbolizes something that we in in
previous times look to and marvel that
and desired to have even if that's an
impossible desire the last man says what
are what are these things I don't care
about them says the earth has been small
become small and upon it hops the
ultimate man who makes everything small
everything becomes trivial everything
fits into its nice little place is
non-threatening
and can be dealt with he says his race
is exterminated
the ultimate man claims to have found
genuine human happiness we have found
happiness other people before us we're
looking for that how fortunate for us
that we actually are happy so what does
a happy life look like for the ultimate
man nature goes on and tells us they
left the places we're living was hard
they like nice warm places
you still love ones neighbor and you rub
against them because you need warmth so
there you know social creatures and he
says sickness and mistrust countess tins
with them you know you shouldn't be sick
shouldn't be mistrustful just go with
things you know the model could be oh
man it's all good
right he says a little poison now and
then that produces pleasant dreams and a
lot of poison at last for a pleasant
death and you know if you want to kill
yourself that's fine you know the
world's not gonna lose anything you
altima man when you kill yourself and if
you want to poison yourself a little bit
so you have some nice dreams that's
that's cool too you know it's your your
body your life
he says they still work but they don't
work to produce anything work he says is
entertainment but they take care of the
entertainment does not exhaust them so
their lives are lives that are you know
in large respect enjoying themselves
they are happy they get to to live in
freedom and comfort and you know
watching streaming shows all they want
you know consuming content that's
created by somebody and they all do and
perhaps do some work but not too much
they just work you know and have fun
with their work and if it doesn't come
out right that's ok too it doesn't
really matter
they even he says have quarrels but they
make sure that their quarrels are soon
made up otherwise indigestion would
result it's not like you know well it
would destroy society or would make me a
bad person oh you just don't want to
feel bad about these sorts of things so
you you know
disagree about the aesthetic value I
mean thinking about this you know we get
into arguments about the Marvel Universe
and you know should this cape have gone
this way and people can get really
obsessive about that now our our people
are not last men so they hold very long
grudges about that and write nasty
comments to each other right and create
videos about how this person is
completely wrong but these people would
be more like jovial geeks and nerds and
they'd be like well you know III see it
differently but let's all agree to
disagree you know that's what they see
is happiness and he goes on a little bit
more he says know what nobody grows rich
or poor anymore both are too much of a
burden there are no more social
distinctions of any sort this really
does look like what one vision of a
post-scarcity economy would resemble
doesn't it everybody's taken care of
there's really no meaning to anything we
all just kind of enjoy ourselves we live
until we die and you know that's that
and now would you really be happy in a
in a situation like that there are
probably a lot of people today who would
in fact welcome that and say this is
exactly what we want
and there were some in nature's time who
are saying that as well
there's one other feature of this world
of the last man that we need to talk
about Nietzsche summarizes in saying no
herdsmen and one herd there's nobody
ruling there's nobody in charge
there's nobody giving orders there's
just the way things are and we follow
them and we're all in one big happy herd
or family to use the metaphor that we
used so often here facetiously and and
exploitative Lee so he says who still
wants to rule why would anyone want to
rule who wants to be in charge of this
stuff that's that's too much work why
care about that who obey both are too
much of a burden so everyone wants the
same thing everyone is the same whoever
thinks of all whoever thinks otherwise
goes into the madhouse but they go
voluntarily they're like
well I guess there must be something
wrong with me I guess I'm not
well-adjusted let's see if we can get me
adjusted and then I can fit in and this
is the only possibility for anybody
within that society that is the
situation of the last men they are happy
in their own way but is it really what
we would count as happiness
it sounds good to many people and
Nietzsche tells us that at this point
Zarathustra you know ends his first
discourse and at this point the shouting
and mirth of the crowd interrupted him
give us this altima man of the earth
astre so they cried make us into this
ultimate man you can have the Superman
and all the people laughed and shouted
and then Zarathustra gets sad because
he's like you know I think these people
actually do want that maybe it my words
are wasted on them because you know if
that's really what they want then how
could they possibly understand what I'm
telling them about the race not being
the human race not being finished and us
striving to create something greater
than ourselves instead they want to go
down back into something like a happy
Pleasant anthill where we all have our
nice you know television sets to look at
perhaps virtual reality and you know
food that gets brought to us all the
time and nobody ever does anything new
or even wants to this is something that
a lot of people have taken from this
prologue of the spoke zarathustra and
you know thought about as well perhaps
this is where we're actually heading if
we're not careful
you